off the coast of north carolina
lies a treacherous stretch of water with
strong currents
and shifting sands with the remains of
up to 5
000 ships it's known as the graveyard of
the atlantic
hidden within this eerie resting place
for lost
souls are gangs of sand tiger sharks
photographer and conservationist tanya
hoppermans
has spent over a decade documenting the
shark gang phenomenon occurring here
i started diving around 2009 came down
here to north carolina
and that was the first time that i saw
the sand tiger sharks
it literally changed my life i walked
into work and
quit and left the corporate world behind
and decided to devote my life to
spending time with sharks
working with spotif shark usa tanya is
studying the
thousands of sharks that have made these
shipwrecks their home
these rusting hulks provide the perfect
conditions for marine life to grow
and for predators to hunt but why
sand tiger sharks congregate here in
such large gangs
is still a mystery there are times that
we could see
a hundred and maybe even more sharks in
an aggregation
they really seem to prefer to be around
other sand tiger sharks
we're not quite sure why yet today tanya
and her husband scott
are looking for answers by diving a
wreck known for large groups of sand
tiger sharks
today we're heading out to the wreck in
the caribbean this is a freighter that
was sunk by a u-boat during world war
ii right now she lies about 90 feet
under water
that's where we tend to see a lot of
sand tiger sharks hanging out
tanya is on the front line trying to
discover the secret
that unites these sharks she's taking
photographs
so scientists can study them for vital
clues
inside this housing is the camera that i
use to photograph the sharks
and we have two lasers here on each side
when i take a picture of a shark
these two green dots will show up on the
side of the shark
we can then actually calculate the
length of that shark just from the
photograph itself
then we can go in and identify each
individual shark based on its unique
spot patterns
it's like a fingerprint as to a person
[Music]
i'll kind of give each other's gear a
look over to
all right looks good every dive there's
the possibility of learning
something new about these animals
there's really hasn't been a lot of
research done on them
you know compared to a lot of other
species such as great whites so anytime
we get in the water with them and bring
back any information for the researchers
that i work with
it's a great day good food great
find some sharks
we have 100 feet of visibility clear
blue water
a lot of the wreck is still intact
you can see the big bowel structure it
never gets old
there are just sharks as far as i can
see all around me
these sharks are named after tigers
because of their voracious appetite
but to tanya they're gentle giants
they have these raggedy teeth that makes
them look really fierce
but these sharks are full of personality
sand tiger sharks are probably about
six or seven feet so females being a
little bit bigger than the males
surrounded by a swarm of sharks tanya
begins her search for evidence
as to why so many are here
there are a lot of females every so
often you see a few males
but it's mostly females why is that
with her laser-guided camera tanya
captures her first clue
to solving this mystery
some of the females do have scars from
baiting
when sharks mate the male actually holds
on to the female
with his teeth if we see fresh
mating scars that female may be pregnant
we're finding several pregnant females
why are they grouping together
after photographing the girl gang that
was amazing
there was a lot of sharks tanya tries to
make sense
of this incredible spectacle so what
we're seeing is a big gang of
sand tiger sharks um mostly females
we have so many unanswered questions but
what we're thinking is that maybe these
females are
aggregating together during pregnancy so
that the males don't try to mate with
them again
it could be possible that the females
are kind of banding together
it's kind of a support network they are
choosing to group together like this
and so not all sharks are just
solo predators
sharks could have a social life just
like humans
you